الفضائيون مخلوقات غريبه حياه خارج كوكب
الارض هذا ما يعتقده الكثيرون حيال مقاطع
فيديو وثقها طيارون لاجسام غريبه في
السماء
[موسيقى]
وكاله ناسا لابحاث الفضاء اتفقت على تسميه
هذه الاشياء بظواهر طائرات مجهوله وليس
المخلوقات الفضائيه
البيانات الحاليه وتقارير شهود العيان
وحدها غير كافيه لتقديم ادله قاطعه حول
طبيعه واصل كل حدث غير معروف
مخاوف بشان سلامه السماء السبب الرئيسي
الذي دفع وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه لتشكيل
هيئه تضم خبراء في مجال الفيزياء وعلم
الاحياء الفلكي لدراسه اكثر من 800 حاله
مشاهده لظواهر طائره غير معروفه
[موسيقى]
لقد اكدت للكونجرس ان نسبه صغيره جدا من
التقارير المبلغ عنها يمكن وصفها بالغريبه
ولا تزال دون حل بسبب نقص البيانات
المرتبطه بها
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه سبق وان بحثت
حقيقه الاطباق الطائره مفسره بعضها
بالطائرات المسيره او البالونات وكاله
ناسا اكدت انها لم تعثر على حياه خارج
الارض بعد لكنها تبحث عن ذلك الكثيرون
يشككون في هذه التقارير ويقولون اننا
ستكذب وهناك ما يتم اخفائه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات